joining us here on the rich eisen show
is akeeb talib on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line how are you akeeb
rich i'm all good
uh always a pleasure right back at you
how fun was that game
yes
it was a it was a good time to say the
least
super exciting game back and forth good
quarterback play a lot a lot of big
plays
you know came all the way down to the
wire so that's always the entertaining
game what is kyler murray doing
this year
that you think
might actually be an improvement from
last year because you saw him towards
the end of the year
last year when arizona was beginning to
to falter and miss the playoffs
how different is he now i feel like i
feel like he's doing a lot of the same
that he did last year while he was
healthy i thought i thought
that the cardinals kind of went down
last year when kyler went down when he
started getting injured so you know he
hurt the shoulder hurt the ankle or
whatever injuries he had but i thought
when he was healthy he kind of looked
similar to how he looked this year so
you know that was the beginning of the
season so
look it looked a lot similar to what he
did last year as rich but what about
maybe uh if you were able to zoom with
him or talk to him before the game
different than last year when you saw
him at the the end of last year any
different in terms of his demeanor
personality approach
anything like that uh i think the vibe
of the cardinals just
confident right now they know confident
or often confident on defense and
there's a lot it has a lot to do with
collar because
that's how he that's how he's walking
around right now super confident man
it's his third year in the system
you know he
got a couple accolades now i was not
like young rookie colin murray and i was
like you a household name you right
there with russell wilson and you know
the rest of these guys so
i think you know he a little more
comfortable and you can kind of see that
in his demeanor so who's the best
quarterback in the nfc west then i keep
telling man oh yeah
i don't know
it's it's a it's a bunch of bad ones so
i don't know so talk to him we don't see
where the best is the best one going to
win no i and i know and i know that you
know
i know that but you're not allowed to
give that answer here i'm not going to
lie to you this is sports talk radio the
whole i don't know we'll see how it
place is reasonable i mean i'm not
saying i'm not saying you gave me an
unreasonable answer but uh i
mean we're going off what you did in the
past
if anybody stopped playing football
right now i think we're gonna say
russell wilson the best right
yeah so like literally right now it's
stafford it's russell
right it's kyler and jimmy g is somebody
who started in the super bowl two years
ago you need to win a football game in
the nfc west
in week three let's just say it okay
uh which quarterback do you want on that
field right now i keep to leave in the
nfc west
that's a tough question rich but i'm
gonna go kyler right now
i'm gonna go kyler
really
give me kyla right now yeah why
he
he could dominate a game like
by himself almost i mean he's like
unshackable i mean he gets stacked but i
think he gets sacked when he when he
really waiting for a rock to clear clear
clear and then you know he just tried to
get up out of here a little bit late but
man it's he hard to stop
he hard to stop his pocket awareness his
arms his arm talent is as good as
the pocket passes right
it's no one questions his arm telling at
all not he hasn't had like the lamar
stuff about can he throw on the outside
he never had to deal with any of that
but his pocket presence and his leg
talent is just as talented as anybody in
the nfl he can escape and keep his eyes
downfield like russell or he can get out
of there and run like lamar so i feel
like he he kind of both of them put
together plus he could throw like the
the lawrence
i mean he's a total package so i'm
taking kyla akeeb talib here on the rich
eisen show fresh off of calling the
uh the barn burning finish between
arizona and uh minnesota yesterday on
fox with gus johnson uh tom brady just
keeps doing it akeeb talib i mean what
did you see from tom that was different
from anybody else you played with and i
know
you played with peyton was there any
anything like where he stands out a
moment where he stood out
at any point in time for you keep to
leave uh
i think just his competitiveness
you really could feel
like some guys might be super
competitive but you know
they're not like our kids to leave they
ain't gonna tell you about it right you
can't really see it like that like i'ma
show it i feel like tom one of them got
to like he's just so competitive
that's why he that's why he ain't never
gonna stop playing football he just love
winning that much so you gonna keep on
playing so
that's the one thing that separates him
from all the rest of the quarterback
smith just that competitive edge that he
played with yeah and gronk looked like
it's you know 2000
you know
15 16 17 again it's insane they're
they're just doing
so well together again how how in the
world does this tampa get derailed this
year and by who they keep to leave
what do you think it is it's gonna be
tough rich i don't i don't think long as
they healthy
i don't think nobody will do it i think
tom would be sitting at the top of the
throne at the end of the season again
long as they healthy
it's
it's going to be too hard to do it like
you say him and watching two hall of
famers pitching catch all day
that defense is second to none
the old line is good every single
position on a team is
is top tier
so if they healthy
they're gonna be super tough to deal
with what did you think of the uh sunday
night game
between the ravens and the chiefs
i didn't get to watch it live but you
know i caught the highlights
of everything but
a heavyweight fight rich
for home my homes did his job he
got the team in position but you know
that's how football goes it's a team
game right everybody got to do their job
so
lamar get that win that's a huge win for
lamar
lamar played outstanding too just you
know it's hard to
stay in the fight with the chiefs and
lamar
did everything he had to do and he
played it and he made a big boy decision
at the end and he made the play at the
end so i thought that was almost like a
gotta win for lamar he probably felt
like it's a gotta win for me like
if i'm gonna be one of those guys in the
afc and this
the younger assy in the name of the
younger quarterbacks in the fc
i gotta beat this dude i never beat him
before yeah i'm saying
the other quarterbacks beat them they
all beat each other i never beat him so
he probably looked at it like that and
i'm glad he got that done yeah and and i
saw i don't know if again you said you
saw the highlights i don't know if any
of the highlights because you were
traveling back from arizona right after
calling the game um on fox with gus
johnson again aqib talib here in the
rich eisen show i don't know
if you saw
that the nbc cameras caught
uh john harbaugh asking lamar if he
wanted to go for it on that fourth down
that they eventually did go for and win
it how does that affect a team to see
the code even though after the game john
harbaugh said yeah we're going for it i
just kind of wanted to check with him
and make maybe even convince myself we
were doing the right thing but how does
that affect the team do you think seeing
a coach ask the quarterback sort of like
a check with you rather than a check
with me right situation
i mean this
is
and when you get all the guys to believe
in what you're preaching that's how you
have a good team so
it becomes
moments in the game happen where
you're gonna have to kind of stand on
the stuff that you're preaching what
kind of football team we gonna be what
we gonna go out there and do how we
handle ourselves what kind of confidence
we're gonna play with and it's gonna be
moments in the game where you gotta kind
of stand on that so that was one of the
moments and when harbaugh said hey you
want to go for it he's like yeah what
are we going for it and will you go for
it and get it man the morale is 10. if
ocho cinco could could do it on the
matin right until you make the morale of
the ravens go up a little bit because of
that
did belichick ever ask brady if he
wanted to go for it did that ever happen
you ever see that i don't know you know
you know i'm just a cornerback i'm in my
own zone in the game i have my hands
full so i don't know what kind of
conversation conversation they have
really i just don't know because it's
just it again like i just kind of rare
to see something like that i imagine
right to see
um just like let's huddle up let's talk
about it even though they were going to
go for it and it was a no-brainer
because what are you going to do even
with 20 seconds to go you're going to
give mahomes some sort of a shot to get
right a shot uh from one swing of the
leg to try and tie it i mean to try and
win it with no time left i got to keep
to leave here on the rich eisen show all
right let's walk through it what was it
like calling a game with gus what was it
like
it was fun
to
to say the least it was
a good time man good august is a dope
partner
he made it so easy for me and
i think uh hanging out a few times
before we got in the booth and
hanging out the night before i think the
the familiarity made me feel a lot more
comfortable so i thought it was fun i
thought we did a good job well i mean
gus is an all-time great hang uh i know
that in terms of our business oh um
how much what what'd you hang what'd you
what'd you do tell me what tell me uh a
good gus hang story
already
begun
we didn't do much we just out at the at
the lobby part okay we're about 12 and
just hung out man just talk chill talk
football talk life you know
so gus oh gee man so you give me a lot
of game life and everything yeah what do
you what do you tell you what what's
what is the i mean come on rich i i
can't i don't want to say the
conversation
but you know
we had a good conversation who knows
there's a few cocktails involved
i'm gonna have to really think about it
i'll tell you exactly what we talked
about
that might be its own great show in
itself as your prep meeting or something
like that because i've i've been around
gus uh post midnight as well he had he
had shades on that one night i saw him
in carolina as a matter of fact he just
uh we were there for thursday night i'm
serious we were there for a thursday
night game we had just finished
uh we were already back at the hotel and
i think he was calling nix on yes
and he had just finished what he was
doing and he showed up wearing shades
and whatever and it was like
everybody flocked to him everybody just
wanted to talk to gus
because right gus is just it was it was
a lot like that when we was at the bar
[Music]
you know so but what did court like do
you have a good time man you know we was
relaxing that just kind of loosened you
up so now we the next day
you know we just got a nice little vibe
i could i could believe a lot more you
know when i'm comfortable like that i
just love the way i like the idea that
we got a team yeah you should i just
love the way he talks sometimes in the
way that that he he just
i don't know where he comes up like
there was like a tight window
and he said i forget which quarter i
think was conor he put it in a shoe box
is what he said
i heard that i'm like that's a guy
because
he's a man like you were you the legend
like that you like john madden and them
guys you just been doing this so much so
witty that's that's what that's what
make you so great at your job you just
you come up with that stuff did he give
you any tips did he give you any tips
broadcasting as well on that front just
about just talkers i know this is what
game three was that game three for you
for yeah that was game three but man gus
just tell me be me
just do your homework
you know what you're talking about
feel for both teams
and you know talk to me that's how you
tell me just it's just me and you in
there having a conversation talk to me
and you know
give good detail make sure i can
understand that i ain't the football i'm
not like a football genius so when you
explain just make sure i can understand
if i can understand it yes then
the key is the 10 year old kid out there
to understand it so
he just kind of you know
keep me in that line right there so
i just talked to him so i feel like
inviting the game just come in here and
talk
and
worry about nothing they don't worry
about who lit
give all the guys say flowers
you know they do something good let's
let's acknowledge that because
they're going to listen to these replays
now i'm going to listen to it you know
that show the guy some love yep
bit
so yeah and sometimes you got to call it
like you see it you know like if
somebody makes a bad play or they make a
bad decision whatever you gotta you know
and sometimes your your colleagues that
you used to play with might not like it
but at least if they know it's coming
from a position of you doing your job
and going ahead and doing it i mean
that's that's why you you have this
opportunity at cube is you've got the
gift of gab and you also have an
incredible resume
and you know um and and i know just from
my own thing that whenever
um you know we we're we're on game day
morning or wherever we're talking very
rarely do we have to say to each other
uh certainly to michael irvin hey what
suit are you wearing tomorrow because i
don't want to wear the same thing i
imagine
there's no real check with you on that
one either right gus didn't say you're
wearing salmon tomorrow or something
like that you didn't have to have that
conversation because you know
like i said i told you what i do i just
call call challenger
let her do her thing man ask her what
you what color shoes i need to get
usually she get me together so
she got them together again what
official color was that
what is the official color of yesterday
well when she told me honestly i didn't
i didn't know it was gonna be pink okay
when she told me she said nude
like a nude blush so when i heard new
blood you know i kind of thought
more tan like a light tan maybe with
like a
you know i thought tan i thought i nude
i thought that's the first thing i heard
so when she got there it was it was pink
i was like oh conjure is pink and she
was like yeah
that's great you know it was terrific oh
i put it on i liked it so you know
making love it i know a lot i love it
because it's you and it adds to you
being you which is what gus told you you
need to be um that's why you're in that
booth that's your fingerprint man and i
loved it i really loved listening to you
and gus it was great it made me smarter
and boy was that an entertaining game
and you made it more entertaining when's
your when's your next one when's your
next assignment with gus hey i
appreciate that too rich next one me and
gus we got uh the cardinals again at
jacksonville this weekend
[Applause]
honestly you should only call cardinals
games
because i'm starting to like the
cardinals rich i bet because they're lit
i mean they're entertaining and so are
you guys
it's a good time watching that game rich
i'm telling you it's
entertaining defense you got vans joseph
he got all the creative blitzes he do
and they got playmakers on defense man
and uh
you know what the offense gonna do it's
gonna be a super explosive offense so
it's a good time watching that game
you'll be a good one this weekend yeah
and what do you think dion do you think
deandre's gonna get more more balls
after the first quarter what do you
think in this one he's got to be sitting
there yeah he had tape over there him
and pat he was playing physical man that
was that was a good that was a good
performance by pat pete not that he's
kind of he kind
the whole time man right you know i
guess tyler ain't really like that
matchup he didn't get too much
separation they was they was physical
over there they was almost wrestling
over there so
i kind of just stayed away from that but
pat p won't be over there this week so
i'm sure he'll get okay well and plus
you got a pool there in jacksonville
maybe that's where you and gus should
have your uh your meeting beforehand
oh yeah yeah i heard it's a nice little
hotel they don't have a death thought oh
yeah
of course go to the pool uh akeeb uh
like i said i really enjoyed it let's
talk down the line let's keep talking i
really want your thoughts on the season
i appreciate it
will do appreciate you rich and god that
is akeeb to leave everybody right here
on the rich eisen show he and gus colin
jacksonville
hosting arizona
oh boy hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here